j'accueille maintenant guy bedos
alors on va dire la vérité guy j'étais
mardi dernier au trocadéro chanter la
marseillaise avec mes amis du show
business mais et puis beaucoup d'entre
eux m'ont dit que vous aviez apprécié
l'émission avec bernard idées d'hier
j'ai trouvé que bernard henri lévy avait
été absolument parfait il a fait un sans
faute sur le pen je trouve que vous tue
comme tu as été très bien aussi parce
que tu l'as pas franchement à décourager
et je m'étais dit je m'étais fait comme
une sorte de deux farces à moi même
alors que je m'étais juré de ne jamais
venir dans cette émission pour des
raisons qui nous regardent tous les deux
que si la démocratie terrassé le
fascisme après cette émission je
viendrai traquer avec toi pour fêter la
victoire
le pen auront au moins servi à ça il
fallait concilier je vais aller ça mais
c'est le meilleur moment des bruins il a
répondu oui c'est vrai en tous les cas
je suis très heureux que tu sois là ça
lui même un plaisir évident
les
vive la république
ouais alors ce soir là j'avais parlé de
moulinex de l'usiné moulinex à bernard
henri lévy parce que j'habite à argentan
une petite ville de normandie qui
avaient voté massivement pour le pen
justement vision enfin ce qu'on ne
s'occupe pas de la gauche d'en bas quand
on est de la gauche d'en haut
voilà ce qui arrive il ya des accidents
et j'ai vu que vous en parliez dans des
interviews aussi donc finalement c'est
peut-être lui les a rapprochés oui oui
oui il ya effectivement eu un déficit
d'attention de d'intérêt humain pour des
gens qui on était beaucoup trop arrogant
brin trop suffisants beaucoup trop mais
prison dans les allées du pouvoir et
parmi les marques qui les marquises
ronge de la rue de solférino donc j'ai
pas envie de les enfoncer
mais qu'ils surprennent de grâce alors
vous avez été assez prémonitoire parce
que dès le mois de février vous
déclariez michelin moulinex ce que le
gouvernement de gauche laisse faire en
ce moment c'est absolument dégueulasse
voilà donc attendu le 21 avril on peut
dire je pense qu'il n'ya pas y'a pas de
gauche c'est comme en amour il n'y a pas
d'amour il ya que des preuves d'amour il
n'y a pas de gauche et que des preuves
de gauche
j'ose pas nous a énervés quand il a dit
à ses rayons la politique ne peut pas
commander à l'économie alors qu'on
pourrait attendre effectivement d'un
gouvernement de gauche et d'un prêt
ministe de gauche linverse moi j'étais
devant mon peu c
je lui ai dit battant et bien il est
parti mais on va pas parler de jeu cela
puisque maintenant c'est un jeune
retraité il est à l'île de ré
dans une ville dans un petit village qui
a voté le pen je trouve que quand même
la venue si on paye cher
en fait moi j'ai passé mon temps à
critiquer je sais pas mais en même temps
je voulais aider jospin s'est pas en je
voulais que souvent c'est dans
l'acrylique qu'on peut trouver justement
une certaine forme de vérité et je suis
plein et beaucoup de trop susceptible
pour être un homme d'état il faut
pouvoir être susceptible
parce que après on lui donne le bouton
du nucléaire il fait la guerre mondiale
pour un rien parce que s'est disputé
avec sa femme
ça fait peur quand même ça à la gauche
qui nous énerve guise c'est la gauche
patronale vous dites qu'ils s'accordent
du medef celle des réseaux de strauss
kahn des réseaux de femmes soit envie de
faire des non non et puis c'est vrai que
là je sors un peu de mon rôle parce que
sur scène j'ai pour habitude de dire que
je fais du drôle avec du triste là on va
être sérieux ne devrait pas un choix
trop sérieux non plus parce que parce
que je risquais de décevoir
ouais je restais un clown je restais un
satiriste l'humoriste juge pas un
comique moi mais j'aime beaucoup un aveu
de mes copains comique mais cela il
pourrait jouer devant le pen salue jean
n'a pas tandis que moi je skie m'arrive
depuis quelques temps je vote chirac je
viens chez ardisson me téléphone pour me
féliciter
comment ça va finir attention j'ai
failli aller chanter la marseillaise et
pascal obispo que jouer pelle
alors comme disait prémonitoire parce
que toujours en février vous disiez
quand même il ya une sorte de résistance
qui est en train de s'organiser contre
les appareils contre la politique
officielle que mon spectacle marche très
bien il la met à marcher à paris il
marche il marche très bien en province
j'ai rencontré énormément de militants
du parti socialiste qui était prêt à
déchirer leur carte et même d'élus
d'élus régionaux qui qui comprenait pas
comment ils n'avaient pas fait remonter
leurs paroles vers le haut un et ça
c'est vrai pour le parti communiste
aussi je veux dire que parti communiste
ailleurs il ya plein de il ya les
ouvriers qui ont qui ont fait carrément
le passage direct du pc au fn il
commence par chanter l'internationale et
ils finissent en levant le bras juillet
à moi oui arturo oui le brest oui oui et
j'ai j'ai eu la curiosité ressortir le
texte que j'ai pas joué depuis
puis quelques années le pen dans tous
ses appels ou petits aux sans grade et
ce grain c'est exactement mon texte
d'arthur wii qui était en quelque sorte
le clown d'iter je veux dire que si on
sait d'où ça vient
et moi ma valise était prête
et je ne dis même pas la destination
parce que j'aime tant les attendants
législatives je sais pas comment ça va
se presser vous dites quand même c'est
triste à dire mais le meilleur c'est le
pen en termes de bête politique en terme
de spectacle
oui c'est vrai mais il n'était pas
mauvais non plus et fidel castro très
bien aussi je veux dire que les
dictateurs sont très bons mais le talent
ne dit pas tout et ça les a pas empêchés
d'être de terrifiants serial-killer ben
oui oui oui on sait l'extrême droite
c'est l'extrême droite un partout je
suis anglais même pas besoin de remonter
jusqu'à hitler les colonels grecs
pinoche est évident est la plus près de
nous bon bah voilà les opposants on
venait chercher on les sent bien dans
les stades ou dans des caves et en
arracher les ongles je veux dire que
c'est pas on a eu chaud quand même ouais
vous êtes un homme contre oui je suis
plus souvent compte que pour ouais
j'aime mieux dire non que ouais c'est
vrai parce que vous êtes construit
contre votre famille c'est pour ça mes
séries commencent à fuir le psy non
c'est pas le petit a parlé c'est pas bon
c'est vrai vous vous êtes construit
contre votre famille où il opère oui oui
oui l'algérie que l'état revienne je
viens rendre c'est que je suis énervé un
petit peu quand je vois des gens des
petits maîtres style tags et autres qui
veulent nous dire que l'antiracisme
c'est un peu mode pour moi c'est ce qui
a fondé mes convictions j'ai vu trop de
choses se passer en afrique du nord
pendant 15 ans j'ai un truc à les
parents mais vous dites que donc votre
beau père avait une scierie et vous dit
qu'un jour il ya un ouvrier se couper 4
doit donc dans cette scierie et le beau
père réagit pas personne ne porte
secours à cet ouvrier en plus il se fait
engueuler pour nettoyer l'établé oui
parce qu'il avait un peu que je n'ai oui
ben oui c'est ben saoud dans les yeux
d'un gosse ça reste un et j'ai eu des
trucs
alors je dis pas que tous les pieds
noirs étaient
lafreux colonialiste et d'affreux il ya
une deuxième injustice qui a été fait
après 60 oui pour faut des gens qui
s'entendait très bien avec des arrêts
clés juive et qui aurait pu rester
d'ailleurs même certains algériens
disent que la colonisation était pas
bien mais que l'indépendance surtout
cours mais les véhicules à aujourd'hui
c'était pas terrible non plus donc y
avait peut-être une voie médiane 110e
nous amènerait d'ailleurs ami cher à
tapas et chaos car paris 0 k est-ce que
je suis s'est trompé il a quand même
fait la paix en nouvelle calédonie
peut-être qu'il y avait quelque chose
comme ça peut-être que certains français
aurait pu rester
peut-être qu'on aurait pu faire il parce
que ferhat abbas puis relayée par camus
au début il voulait pas faire la
révolution car s'il en est simplement à
ce qu'on ne regarde pas les algériens
comme des sous-hommes
ils demandaient un droit de 26 demandait
des choses qui relèvent simplement de la
dignité humaine alors 2009 mais qui vous
est remonté sur scène mais j'ai dû tout
changer de votre spectacle après ce qui
s'est passé le 21 mai voilà on ne pense
pas à moi voilà parce que moi je trouve
que vraiment le résultat le plus
terrible de tout ça c'est qu'il faut que
il a fallu que je me mette à marnay et à
voir comment je pouvais à bata c'est ce
spectacle et remettre de l'actualité
dans quelque chose qui est d'actualité
ouais eh ben c'est pas mal je crois ça
va votre fils vous a aidé il m'a aidé
nicolas nicolas 22 ans classé c
j'ai un fan il ya une relation entre
nous qui est celle d'un père et d'un
fils mais il m'a aidé pour le spectacle
on a écrit beaucoup de choses on tricote
notre texte ensemble
je rajoute à des trucs qu'il a fait il
rajouta des trucs que j'ai fait et c'est
magnifique que mr alors votre spectacle
il n'y a pas de sketches comme il y
avait une au but à 1 c'est celle du
stand-up dire que vous êtes l'inventeur
il y voit la galerie marassa japon
américains les arabes
djamel vous a dit qu'il faisait du
stand-up c'est-à-dire il ya pas de
sketches et une suite de de réfléchir à
la première personne manière et non me
suis jamais plaint la gale est une porte
et j'ai fait ça pendant un demi siècle
ou presque bon ben voilà
je crois maintenant j'ai perçu quand
j'ai publié un bouquin il ya longtemps
en 75 qui s'appelait je craque
j'ai bien su que j'avais pas besoin de
me cacher des masques et prendre des
accents pieds noirs
monsieur ramirez etc je ne renie pas du
tout je vais m'amuser avec mon ex femme
sophie c'est formidable j'adore cette
période là mais voilà ça a changé et je
pense que je pense rien du tout je
constate que le public s'intéresse à ce
que je dis à la première personne mais
en même temps il ya un décalage je suis
pas comme ça à la maison je sais je dis
je
mais le je est un autre et sur scène bah
oui si j'étais à la maison ou même dans
la vie en général comme je suis sur
cette insupportable
mon entourage et si j'étais sur scène
comme je suis dans la vie je ferais
chier tout le monde est donc la preuve
là tu m'as les deux aires